[Music]
that is jimmy johnson qualifying for
sunday's indianapolis 500 the crown
jewel of auto racing he's trying to
become just the third driver ever to win
the indy 500 and daytona 500 two very
different races johnson captured a
record-tying seven nascar series
championships winning races like daytona
driving stock cars regular vehicles
silhouettes enhanced for racing but two
years ago he switched gears setting out
to drive in open wheeled formula cars
made popular in f1 and indycar a new
career pursuit for a legend of auto
racing and we wanted to know why
let's get things rolling here in saint
pete at the opening race of the 2022
indy car season
26 cars zoomed and zagged their way
through the downtown streets of saint
petersburg florida
with speed limits clearly suspended for
the day this is a jimmy johnson we
haven't seen mixing it up
all right let's do this a few days
earlier i got a feel for the course how
fast will this go
riding shotgun with driver jimmy johnson
i get why you love this i really do
it wasn't johnson's usual ride but we
still hit about 115 miles per hour
formula cars johnson drives on the
indycar circuit reach top speeds of more
than twice that up to 240 miles per hour
and turns out it's the speed that keeps
the car from flying off the track
oftentimes i've found that i'm like oh
no it's it's
i'm at the edge of traction like
actually no you're going too slow so you
you start backing off and you need to go
faster faster
that speed means drivers can experience
up to five g's on turns or five times
their body weight
as for the car itself it features an
open wheel cockpit with drivers sitting
just two inches off the ground
it's a far cry from the stock cars
johnson mastered racing for more than
two decades in nascar a legend in the
sport he's the only driver ever to win
five straight nascar cup series
championships though he'd end his nascar
career after three winless seasons
retiring in 2020 in those three years of
not winning i also realized just how
much fun i wasn't having and at the time
i really felt like i was done with
full-time racing but as i got some
elevation from
from the sport i realized that i was
just ready for some for a new challenge
this is kind of the tub area what we
call it that's when he made the move to
indycar in many ways
like starting from scratch
how much did you have to break down what
you knew already to go into indycar it's
been a complete reinvention and there's
no one more surprised than myself
honestly
they are two
completely different disciplines and you
know there are many open wheel drivers
that have tried nascar and only a few
that have gone this way but i now see it
johnson's had to learn on the fly a
rookie all over again when he began
training two years ago i was driving
anything with an open wheel environment
and wings on it
including some lower division formula
cars with kids that are literally still
in school i mean their tutors were at
the race track their parents were there
they didn't have a driver's license and
you know here's 45 46 year old seven
time now
great yeah
hey kids
how's it going thank you that's awesome
it was wild because many of those
moments
reminded me of why i'm even doing this
what do you love about driving
there's an experience
on track that
takes me back to being the five-year-old
jimmy riding my dirt bike johnson's been
racing nearly as long as he's been able
to walk i found this under the christmas
tree
on christmas morning when i was four
years old were you the daredevil kid
i would say out of my crazy friends i
wasn't the craziest a lot of the friends
that i grew up racing motocross with you
know quickly doing backflips and all the
wild jumps that they do that was never
my my thing so i feel like i was more
sane than the rest certainly
but sane might not be the word everyone
would use to describe auto racing
especially moving from stock cars to
formula cars more exciting
it is more unknown more exciting without
a doubt scarier
uh yeah wrong word to use maybe when i
would use i'm going to put my bag then
and perhaps his family
johnson and his wife shanny have two
daughters
and while they all have a knack for
competition
that need for speed is definitely from
dad's dna
is there a daredevil side to you
at all
no
[Laughter]
i'm not
an adrenaline seeker
managing risk like you just see the
computer running like i really need to
do this do you really need to do this
that's the question shanny asked when
jimmy was contemplating getting back
behind the wheel for answers the
johnson's turned to their friend and
coach four-time indycar champion dario
franchitti what i love about jimmy is he
he wanted it to be a family decision he
said i really can't do this if you're
not on board i had a few questions i was
like what do you think honestly
safety wise and is this a crazy idea
he said of course that's crazy but
you know if anyone can do it jimmy can
as i said last year he's got the
enthusiasm of a rookie
with the mindset of a seven-time
champion the first race i was a wreck
and each race i got a little more
comfortable with him in those cars and
this year has been definitely
much more enjoyable
this year johnson's first full-time
season meaning he's competing on both
the street courses like saint pete and
for the first time the ovals like the
famed track at indianapolis motor
speedway the brickyard site of this
weekend's indy 500. johnson already has
four nascar victories on the track but
driving and what's been dubbed the
greatest spectacle in racing has
remained one of his lifelong dreams
my household on memorial day weekend
when i was a little kid growing up it'd
be my grandfather my father myself and
my brothers watching the indy 500. as
the date gets closer i find myself
watching old videos and remembering oh i
was on the couch and i saw that happen
does he call you in when it's like
you've got to see this one wait this is
the one from 1972 oh yes oh all the time
all the time we're just watching one the
other day with emerson fidel hall right
mario andretti rick mears you know these
these greats that are out there dueling
it out
johnson is trying to become a part of
that indy 500 lore while he's just
outside the top 20 in the current
indycar standings he'll start the race
in the 12th position among 33 cars no
matter the outcome for now johnson says
he's just trying to enjoy the ride i'm a
competitor and i want to win but
where i am in life you know i spent a
large part of my career motivating
myself and oftentimes being unhappy yeah
worrying about winning
but i don't have to continue to do that
i don't have to continue to be that way
and that's been a big revelation for
myself and it took those tough final
years of nascar to realize it like
i want to win i don't have to win you
can be a kid on the dirt bike
i want to be out there and i've also
found that i have an 11 year old and an
eight-year-old that are watching closely
and they they identify with that and
that's possibly the most important thing
absolutely just amazing perspective and
i cannot stress enough i mean he
dominated nascar so for me to see this
switch
just amazing wishing him the best great
stuff yes
the dish is next stick
i only around
be your saturday